(mysterious dreamy dance music)
- [Narrator] Located in Madagascar
is a forest unlike any other.
Because if you look closely,
this forest is made of stone.
The Tsingy de Bemaraha, also
known as Tsingy Stone Forest,
is made of limestone,
which was once underwater
some 200 million years ago.
The rocks all feature distinct,
razor-sharp formations,
created by erosion from tropical rain,
which washed away the softer stone.
The reserve is around
230 square miles in size,
and the stone towers rise
220 feet from the ground.
Although this dramatic landscape
appears inhospitable to nature,
Tsingy is home to some
very resilient wildlife,
including numerous wild bird populations
and 11 different species of lemur.
The word Tsingy is indigenous
to the Malagasy language
and aptly translates to where
one cannot walk barefoot.
However, while one cannot walk barefoot,
the Tsingy Stone Forest is accessible
to those wanting to see and
climb the forest in real life.
(sonic beeping)